[Music]
all right okay
well as Courtney already said the title
of my talk is future JavaScript what is
still missing what can you expect from
this talk in recent years javascript has
grown considerably especially ACMA
script six has been a huge release of
ECMO script and now it's already nicely
well rounded language so modules added a
lot and with for example async iteration
the whole story of a synchronicity is
quite nice now in JavaScript and that
leads to the question are there still
features that are missing so what would
still be even with all the things we
already have what would still be nice to
have and what I'll be talking about is
my opinion I'll talk about the features
that I consider most important only have
there a lot of others that may or may
not be useful but there's also a risk of
loading the language if you add too much
and most of the things I show you are
actually based on official feature
proposals so it's a legitimate look into
the future of JavaScript first I'd like
to give you a little background with
regard to how JavaScript is actually
designed and with a coma script 6 we had
well as I said before of a huge release
so that has a few problems so after Ecco
script 6 tc39 than is the committee that
evolves javascript decided to adopt a
more agile approach and now the focus is
on features not on
releases anymore so people will write
proposals for features these features go
through stages from zero to four and
then you have release once a year and
due to the stages it becomes it's a it's
a very simple process you have the
deadlines and whatever feature has
reached State Stage four at that point
it becomes part of the release so that's
nice and incremental nicely agile this
is what this process looks like you can
see the stages from zero to four and two
things I'd like to point out is or well
extra several you have these
requirements before you can enter a new
stage and even for stage zero tc39 has
to have had a look at your proposal so
you have to present your proposal in in
front of tc39 and then the proposal is
at stage zero another thing that I find
interesting and very important is before
you can enter stage two can you see how
you can see the cursor before you can
enter stage two there have to be two
implementations of your feature so stuff
you propose is actually tested in the
wild and it's not this kind of abstract
specification and that is really nice
and before a feature reaches stage four
there have to be acceptance tests for
the feature and that ensures that the
the various JavaScript engines are
compatible and it's it's amazing how
compatible they are and that's due to
this test suite we'll start with
desirable features that are related to
values right now if you compare values
in JavaScript
there is a distinction there are two
kinds of values on one hand you have
primitive values and these are compared
by value so you look at if you compare
two values you look at the content and
you compare the content and that's why
these two strings here are considered
equal on the other hand whenever you
have an object and arrays are objects
too
then you don't look at the content you
compare the identity and these are two
different objects with the same content
and those are considered to be not equal
what would be nice to have is if you for
example if you're implementing something
custom like a point or a complex number
would be nice to have is comparison by
value for objects so how could that be
done and there's unfortunately there's
currently no proposal two possibilities
are so well the the foundation is that
you have to have a new kind of object
that is compared differently and to go
with this new kind of object what you
want is a new new factories for objects
and that could be for example a new kind
of literal for objects and here you're
creating two value objects that are
compared by value and these have the
same content and now they're considered
to be equal the other possibility is
again complementary it doesn't exclude
the other possibility would be to have a
new kind of class or to just tag a class
as one that produces value objects value
types and value objects also help with
later structures because at the moment
if you're putting if you're using
objects as keys that almost makes no
sense
well unless you're using a week map so
or really III offhand I can't come up
with a use case because if you're adding
the same object twice you get as a key
you get two entries as you can see here
so we've added two different entries
because again we're comparing by
reference by identity another value
related feature is are the so called
begins because right now what you have
is when you use JavaScript numbers you
have 53 bits plus a sign for integers
and if you go beyond this range there
are holes in the in the space so they're
two javascript numbers represent or know
the same JavaScript number stands for
two mathematical integers so we can see
that here if here we are at the upper
end of the range and if we add one
nothing changes so there's a whole after
nine nine two on the other hand if you
use begins whose proposal is at stage
three at the moment you don't have any
such problems because the size of a big
int
grows as necessary so if you've if you
always add one and the number grows
larger more bits are added as needed to
represent of any any number you need and
here you can see if we the they have
this this suffix n which means that
there are begins and if you're adding
one end to the number that
ends with nine and two you actually you
really do increment by one and if you
want fixed size of integers for example
if you're working with 64-bit numbers
integers for data bases what you can do
is you can cast and here we're casting
two operands and afterwards we cast the
result of multiplying them and that
ensures that we always correctly stay
within 64 bits but usually you'll just
use begins like that and they'll grow as
necessary another value related feature
is computation with base ten floating
point numbers at the moment javascript
numbers are base two floating point
numbers and then you have the classic
here that sometimes used to to make fun
of javascript but actually that's an
issue that other languages have have
just as well so if you do the same
computation and say python you get the
same issue and because python as well as
javascript they're both the numbers are
based on the on I Triple E standards so
that's nothing JavaScript specific if on
the other hand you have base ten
floating-point numbers you don't get any
problems and the result is as you'd
expect and that matters whenever you do
scientific computing in JavaScript and
it also matters when you work in FinTech
and do any kind of financial computation
so if you do your taxes in JavaScript
you don't want there to be any rounding
errors
when it comes to categorizing values
javascript is also a tiny bit quirky you
have to decide if you want to use type
of instance of depending on the check
you want to perform a type of has its
own set of quirks typeof null is the the
famous one that null is the type of
things that now is an object which it
isn't instance of has the issue that if
a an instance or a class comes from
another realm like a frame in in a web
browser then instance of doesn't work as
you'd expect the next group of features
is about functional programming if you
look at languages that have syntax that
comes from the C family then they make
an unfortunate distinction between
expressions and statements so
expressions are syntactic constructs
that produce values when they're
evaluated and statements are constructs
that do something and that leads to
JavaScript having two kinds of
conditional constructs so on one hand
you have the the ternary operator which
is an expression that does an if then'
else and then you have an if then else
statement there is a proposal that is
called do expressions and this proposal
lets you use statements in expression
contexts so what you do is you use these
curly braces you tack them with a du and
then this is a do expression and inside
it you can use several statements and
these statements themselves act a little
bit more like expressions so the last
value that is mentioned but
the result of the whole do expression
and that is very useful whenever for
example for setting up constants because
you can do it in one step in one block
what you'd actually wise have to do
externally so that is one nice use case
react will profit from that as well
because in react you often have like you
use the ternary operator a lot and with
do expressions you have more room and
you can use nicer syntax
pattern-matching is another feature that
is inspired by functional programming
and pattern matching is nice whenever
you have to switch cases depending on
the structure of data so if for example
you're processing syntax trees or if
you're working with nested json data
then this is this is really nice and
it's partially based on the structuring
so you're both checking the structure so
here we're checking the property status
is 200 but he also can extract something
out of the data and then it's done via
destructuring here example here for
example we extract the content length
into the variable s so that's nice and
the proposal for that is currently at
stage 1
then there's the pipeline operator there
are two competing proposals we look at
one of them the the one i like better
and that one is called smart pipelines
and the pipeline operator works as
follows it's useful whenever you have
deeply nested functional applications
with the pipeline operator you can write
those in more in a more intuitive way
because you show the flow of the data
because if you if you look at the whole
computation what you start with this
actually the X and that is the input of
an F and the output of applying F to the
X is fed into G the result is fed into H
so whenever you have a multiple step
process when you compute something the
pipeline operators is really nice and a
sub feature for the pipeline operator
that I really like is it could have
potentially have built in partial
application the way this works is you
have a place holder in here so that's
the hash symbol some people also say the
hashtag symbol and then the and what's
cool about that is you can actually
implement functions tool functions and
then use them as if there were methods
so what we're doing down here is we're
importing two functions from for my
utility module and then thanks to
partial application we can pipe them or
chain them as we otherwise would methods
so that makes it really easy to extend
classes or objects externally and use
them in a functional way you don't have
to add new methods another group of
features concerns concurrency and here
at the moment the de facto standard is
the worker API and that API has recently
also been added to no chess which is
really nice to have the same api on both
platforms one problem with the workers
is they're relatively heavyweight each
worker has its own realm and for example
it comes with its own global variables
guarding a worker takes time and
resources and what I would like to have
is something more lightweight we can
start processes in a more light with
manner and one language that does that a
lot
and and it's very productive and with it
and uses that to great effect is hora
Lang as an example so I wait concurrency
would be nice to have another group of
features is the standard library and
this is where JavaScript at the moment
has the most deficiencies warbled
efficiency is not the right word looks
the most feeble when compared with other
languages that have a richer standard
library and that is something that is
also at the moment being considered by
tc39 how to best extend it because it
doesn't come for free I mean with
upgrading is for example it's easier if
you just host a module in NPM and with
the standard library you really just
want to have the core functionality and
one kind of cosmetic thing that I would
like to see is at the moment javascript
has several namespace objects and these
are kind of poor-man's modules and they
exist because in the beginning they
wanted to group sets of functions but
javascript didn't have modules yet so
what you did was you just introduced the
namespace object instead it'd be nice if
they were actually built in modules and
this is what this could look like you'd
introduce a special protocol to have
this kind of identifier for for built-in
modules and it's import function max
from this module you would use it down
here and this is opposed to the current
way of doing things
we'll use the name space object math
and the advantage is that the language
becomes more modular and if he imports
something from a module the the invoking
that is quicker than doing finding a
property on on an object such as math
one functionality that I think should
definitely be added to the standard
library our helps for iterables and
ideally or it should be both synchronous
iterables and asynchronous intervals and
at the moment if you have an iterable
like up here this is a set if you want
to do anything with it such as filter it
you have to convert it into an array
before you can process it further and if
you had actually a helper that worked
directly with iterables you could do it
like down here you could apply filter
directly to the iterable and produce
another iterable and that would allow
nice on-demand pipelining of the whole
thing so that would be really great to
have Python is inspiring in that regard
they have a module it's called itertools
and they have a lot of tool functions
for iterables immutable data or support
for immutable data will also be nice at
the moment we have among others two
libraries that are possible popular the
first one is called imir it's more
lightweight it works directly with
object and arrays and but processes them
in never mutates anything and then you
have immutable j/s and that one is more
heavyweight and has its own data
structure so something in that vein
would be nice to have in the standard
library
better support for date times would be
really cool as well because at the
moment the best practice for JavaScript
dates is don't use them or at least not
directly
there are several nice libraries out
there thankfully tc39 is working on an
updated date api and that one is called
temporal
here you see that we work with an
abstract date/time instance or day time
and then we use it relative to a or we
use a timezone down here and and just
using time zones at the moment with the
data API is not much fun and lastly a
few features may actually not be needed
so one is optional chaining that is very
popular so I'm not going to say too much
against it I'm just just the here if you
dig deeply into an object valve and you
chain property accesses you can use this
operator and whenever there's an
undefined or null in-between you just
get undefined or null at the end so it's
it's safe that way on so it's nice and
concise but there's a con you should
avoid deeply these deeply nested
accesses because your data becomes
harder to change if you do that and
being this tolerant can hide problem
setup and that surface later on so the
alternatives are to pre-process the data
before you work for it and make it work
with it and make it more compact or to
have dealt helper functions that extract
data and what may not be needed either
is operator overloading that would be of
a simpler solution and that would be in
fix function application down here so
we'll see how that plays out
but it's it's easier to understand it's
relatively easy to use and yet if you
have nested expressions they look as
nice as if you had real operator
overloading so that is a potential
alternative alright so let's get to the
takeaways at the moment javascript is
already a fairly well rounded language
the main wishes that I have are value
types begins and big decimals the
pipeline operator lightweight
concurrency and a bigger standard
library and if you want to download the
slides this is the QR code for it this
is the URL where you can find the slides
you can read so this blog post is a
transcription and my JavaScript books
are free to read online thank you
[Applause]
[Music]